so you tackled stormville and defeated
godric to grafton the most cowardly lord
of them all honestly god dick's nothing
more than a jumped up country bumpkin
and you've finished or at least mostly
finished leone of the lakes and the
academy of rail lucaria but now
things are getting real and you have a
lot of choices ahead of you do you head
to the hellscape that is caled or do you
head up to the altus plateau well i'm
here to help guide you along your
journey like your own personal guidance
of grace here is the best route to take
post learning of the lakes first things
did you go into sierra for river and
einsail river before anything else i
highly recommend taking on these two
areas sierfa river can be found at the
well located here on a map within this
wood is by far one of the coolest areas
of the game so do yourself a favor and
head there next up einsall river is
located at the well here on a map within
leonia east and if you haven't already i
would honestly recommend taking on carry
a manor a mini legacy dungeon located
here on the map and the academy of rail
lucaria before moving on as everything
beyond this point is going to be a major
step up in terms of challenge and
difficulty
the next area we're going to go to are
certain parts of caled caled is an
extremely rough area and honestly much
of it i'm going to recommend heading to
later but there are a couple easier
spots to tackle and ones that will
progress important npc quest lines that
i want you to hit up here so first i
want you to go to celia town of sorcery
it's located here on a map if you want a
quick and easy way to get there go to
the dragon burnt runes in limgrave
located here and find the sellers within
the ruins one of the sellers happens to
contain a transporter trap that will
warp you right into cellular crystal
tunnel you should be at a level by now
where you can at least escape fairly
easily and handle the enemies here the
boss is still pretty rough so if you
want to take it on go ahead otherwise
feel free to escape at this point once
you leave head to your left or east and
you'll reach the celia understand sight
of grace and therefore sell you a town
of sorcery go ahead and tackle this and
try to chat up gowri and millicent while
you're at it a big reason i'm taking you
here is to complete this npc quest line
so once you finish chatting up gowri
head into aeonia swamp and the heart of
aeonia located here where you'll have to
fight commander o'neal once you beat him
progress millicent and gallery's
storyline until millicent has visited
gallery shack and left if you haven't
done it yet head up north to grails
dragon borough via spirit spring just
north of the celia graveyard and church
of the plague
here you'll meet the giant dragon i'm
dubbing grail you can defeat him one of
two ways either slowly whittle away at
his health by avoiding the dragons i
recommend equipping bleed to a weapon as
you do this otherwise it will take
forever or you can tackle him by
defeating the baby dragons he spawns i
recommend this method simply because it
will help you learn how to defeat pretty
much every single dragon in the game
also if you want to farm they drop a
decent amount of runes so instead of
killing them all you can kill a few rest
at a sight of grace which will respond
them and grails health and then rinse
and repeat
directly east of grail is the fort
fereth site of grace and fort fereth
itself the fork can be difficult to
tackle but if you make it through your
reward is half of the dectus medallion
if you haven't already the other half
can be found at fort height which is
located here on a map you can also get
radigan's source sealed by exploring
here which greatly raises your vigor
endurance strength and dexterity that
said it also increases how much damage
you take so if you want a glass cannon
build this is probably going to be a
good one while you can tackle the boss
of the area at this point star scourge
radon i'm going to highly recommend you
don't instead we're now going to head
into the altus plateau you can reach it
one of two ways either you can use the
ground lift of dectus located here now
that you have both medallions or you can
work your way through a dungeon by going
through the ravine veiled village and
the rune strewn precipice i recommend
taking on the dungeon as you should be
able to tackle it at this point and it
will net you more items and levels we're
going to pop out at the altus plateau
the altus plateau is difficult but it
should be within reason directly to your
west is mount gelmere but we're going to
avoid that for now what i want you to do
is head east and back towards the ground
lift of dectus this will bring you to
the altus highway and the altus highway
junction and i bring you here because
you're pretty much surrounded by five
golden seeds to your north is one golden
seed located here directly to your east
is the main gate to landel run past the
tree sentinels and you'll find the outer
wall phantom tree side of grace which
has two golden seas right by it head
north and you'll find two more golden
seeds feel free to avoid any of these
bosses if you do want to take on the
tree sentinels i advise you start from
the outer wall phantom tree side of
grace head back towards them and try to
take on the tree sentinel to your left
without going onto the staircase if you
can beat him here you won't wake up the
other one and you can take them on one
at a time instead of both at once now go
back to the altus highway junction site
of grace head directly north and you'll
reach the forest spanning great bridge
plus a warp take this warp which will
transport you across to the other side
of the broken down bridge from here go
ahead and explore the windmills north of
you try to take on the bosses and
explore the altus plateau for whatever
dungeons you'd like when you're ready
from windmill village head east and
south along the path where you'll
essentially go through the back entrance
of lane del instead of the main gate and
not have to worry about two tree
sentimentals at once continue east and
you'll find a tree sentinel guarding the
capital rampart
take him on and you'll be able to enter
lane dell capital city to be clear
because it was something i was freaked
out about you can beat the boss of this
legacy dungeon without needing to worry
about the game ending you will progress
some storylines but there's plenty of
story left and the game is far from
ending
also within lane dell you can find a
well you can go into located here which
will take you to the underground
roadside and dungeon of landell the
subterranean shining grounds i don't
think you're at a level where you can
tackle it yet but make sure to at the
very least find this note it and get the
sight of grace
when you finish lane dell you can now
choose to either head into mount gelmere
the area north of lane dell or back to
caled i'd ignore the area north of lane
dell for now and instead either tackle
dungeons in mount gelmere or finally
finish up most of kalid the one thing
i'm going to say here before you do any
quests in volcano manor i recommend
taking on star scourge radon i know he's
an extremely tough fight but if you do
the volcano manor quest you can risk
taking out some of your allies before
attempting to fight star scourge radon
so it's time to finish up most of kalid
and starskirch radon don't worry too
much about the divine tower of caled
basement unless you want to or any of
the bosses around the beastial sanctum
or to the north side of grail's dragon
barrow
as a heads up once you finish defeating
star scourge radon if you return to red
main castle and speak with witch hunter
geron in the backside he'll disappear
and redmayne castle will become a mini
legacy dungeon which you should
definitely be able to handle after radon
finally radon and lane del complete it's
time to head into the volcano manor
just kidding before we do that there was
a major change in the lands between
after you defeated radon head back to
fort height and you'll see this
amazingness in front of you it relates
to ronnie's questline i had you start in
my lyria guide so head down here take on
the challenge and see where all of this
leads you
now once you finish all of that time to
actually take on the volcano manor if
you're having trouble definitely feel
free to head north of lane delta level
up in that new region before finishing
volcano manor
and that takes you through the mid game
content of elden ring i hope this guide
helped for recap i pretty much
recommended going in this order altus
plateau caled and then mount gel mirror
and i'll see you guys next time for more
videos on alden ring peace
[Music]
you